hello folks welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany the only
site on the internet that does physics
everybody else does
mathematics
they move concepts around
anyways uh today i
think i'm going to be skipping over the
comments and questions
okay because i've got a
full plate
with a subject matter i'll be touching
upon today
and
in fact i'll be skipping space as well
i'm gonna postpone that until wednesday
uh i was gonna talk about space today
but um again i've got my plate full with
what i've got here so
take that as a rain check as false
advertising on my part
and i'll touch upon that on wednesday
okay so what am i going to be talking
about today um i'm going to be talking
about this fellow
who made a video 45 minute video
criticizing different aspects of
my
um
science the uh series okay
and he attacked each point
and i think it was good that he did that
because first of all i was in the
process of doing all these things
uh so it kind of his criticism
puts it in the right perspective
uh the other reason is that this fellow
um
he's uh
he essentially represents
what i would say at least 99 of the
people out there believe science and the
scientific method are
about okay so
uh
i think it comes in very handy what he
did
uh to
[Music]
you know come here and uh
present rejoinders rebuttals to what he
had to say
okay so um
what's first of all different from our
site to all the rest well uh
what we've been doing
what the mathematicians have been doing
for the last
2500 years at least if not more
certainly more than that
is they
simulated everything with particles
discrete particles
and
they have no problem answering those
visible things things we can see and
touch
the problem is when they apply those
particles
to the invisible world of mother nature
when they apply it to
gravity when they apply it to light when
they apply it to magnetism that's where
they run into trouble you cannot explain
a single one of those invisible
intangible phenomena with particles with
discrete particles
so this is just a quick uh
illustration of the difference of the
differences between what mathematical
physics does and what the whole world
does out there and what we do in this
site okay
and here it is essentially for the last
10 thousand years the rest of the world
everybody else does everything with
discrete particles
and of course with that you cannot
explain action at a distance you cannot
explain how one particle here affects
another one over there that's the whole
problem
okay or a big portion of the problem
okay
and what we do here instead we say that
all atoms in the universe are physically
interconnected they're not
interconnected like attached
the same thread that you see there
weaves around and not only makes the
atoms but the interconnections
that's that's the proposal that's the
assumption with which we work here okay
so this uh shows you that we are a
little different than everybody else and
of course when you look at that you say
well yeah with this you can explain
action at a distance because there is no
real true genuine
action at a distance there is something
between any two atoms
and it's something that we cannot see or
touch
okay so that i guess puts it in the
right perspective
okay so what did this fellow say well um
the other day i started with analyzing
what he said and the first thing he
mentioned was that um he thought
that science was alive and well
that for 2500 years at least
uh we've done
we've made progress
and that especially we made progress in
the last 200 years he said
and the other day i criticized that i'm
saying that we have made not only no
progress in 2500 years
but in the last 200 years more likely
like 150 years
we've gone backwards
you know we we stopped doing rationality
before they tried to do rationality
after you would say end of the
19th century all the way to today
they abandoned rationality completely
all the explanations all the physical
interpretations are irrational they're
not wrong they're not right they're not
wrong they're irrational
they make no sense whatsoever and it's
not surprising that all the
mathematicians always say you know a lot
of them say that and people are not
listening to them but they say
we don't understand it we cannot explain
it
and people out there the layman a lot of
them say sure you can
sure you understand it because otherwise
we wouldn't have all this technology
and they don't realize that technology
is not a um
a proof evidence or anything related to
uh
theories to the explanation the person
gives for why or how something works in
other words mechanisms and causes
specifically
and so laymen usually are out of touch
with that they think that because you
have a computer that verifies that
quantum is correct
and if you have gps it proves that
general relativity is correct
absolutely not you know gps does not
prove that time is a physical object
that is warped and computers don't
prove
that a particle can be at two places at
once
so it's the theory the explanation they
give you which is irrational and which
the mathematicians tell you in your face
that they do not understand it and
they're absolutely right they do not
understand it
okay and so this fellow um
raised a second issue
following up on the one that i mentioned
the other day
and that is that uh you know
you can criticize the
scientific method as he calls it i call
it the religious method or the
mathematical method
but he says you can criticize it but be
sure you understand
be sure you understand what science is
attempting to achieve
that's going to be the argument that i'm
going to be addressing today tonight
okay
so let's see what he had to say okay
listen carefully here i'm going to put
it on there okay
pay attention here it goes hold on
the questions addressed in this rebuttal
are
is there a rational way to do science
and
what problems does science attempt to
solve
science is a construct so there's no
inherent way to go about science the
universe doesn't say this is how science
must be done essentially humans thought
okay what is a good way of finding out
more about the universe and from that
they came up with the scientific method
if you disagree with the scientific
method then sure feel free to challenge
it but make sure you actually understand
what problems the scientific method is
trying to solve
okay so that's what he had to say about
that's the issue today
and yes i guess uh
you need to define what science is about
if you're gonna
talk rationally about science okay so
you need to define
the
scope of science what is science about
especially as it relates to physics
that's what we do here okay so we're
going to be talking about physics
science as it relates to physics and yes
you need to define the scope
and the question is yeah you can
criticize it but like he said you need
to find out you know what is science
attempting to achieve
okay and so here's a little rundown of
uh
what the issues are okay
is there a rational way to do science
so it's not a question of what to do if
it's the right way or the wrong way
it's whether it's there's a rational way
of doing science that's the issue
this is not an issue of right or wrong
which are opinions this is an issue of
is it rational or is it irrational okay
that's the question
and so he proposes the right approach
uh yeah but you know you have to ask the
right questions okay and find out what
science is trying to achieve and what is
the scientific method attempting to
achieve and what is its purpose
i mean
uh and again as it relates to physics i
mean why are we doing science why are we
doing physics what is the purpose what
is our goal what are we trying to learn
or understand or whatever okay so we
need to put that in the right
perspective
and i'm going to be arguing that for the
last 2500 years we have never put in the
right perspective
in other words people had the right
perspective but they never formulated it
in an official way okay i guess the
closest to that maybe is aristotle okay
that he kind of said this is what we're
trying to achieve okay but they forgot
about that long ago you know that they
don't do that anymore especially in the
17th century when they introduced
experiments
they said you need to do an experiment
as part of the scientific method
and that's when they screwed it up and
why did they screw it up because
uh they want to do an experiment
they want to go to a lab what they call
it now falsification verification any of
those words
they want to go to the lab
and they want to see and touch run an
experiment which with that which is
intangible
and
invisible
you can't see the mediator of
magnetism for example or of gravity and
they want to go to the lab and do an
experiment
what to detect that which is intangible
and invisible
so this is where the problem is you
cannot use experiments which is what
they've been doing for the last 400
years to try to figure out
you know
what is out there in the invisible world
of mother natures that
triggers that causes or is the mediator
of light gravity magnetism electricity
and so on this is where the problem is
and uh so we need to zero in on what
we're trying to achieve with
science meaning physics right in this
case
and
you can't use in order to define the
term science or the term physics right
you can't rely on any of these you can't
rely on
a show of hands
what we call democracy okay this is not
a question voting because if everybody
votes for the flat earth
uh theory that doesn't make it right
mother nature laughs at those people
okay so you can't say we're gonna just
find out if we have 50 plus one and and
that's the winner now and aside from the
fact that tomorrow that may change
tomorrow maybe it drops to
50 percent minus one okay someone
changes his mind so what are we gonna do
just keep voting until we get it right
so no you can't use democracy to resolve
this issue
then uh you can't rely on authority you
can't say well let's ask the professors
because they were brainwashed by the
previous professors who were brainwashed
by the previous professors the only way
they could have gotten a degree out
there is if they parroted what the
previous generation told them because
otherwise they wouldn't get a degree
first of all in a second they wouldn't
get a job or a
a career
and so
yeah this is where the problem is you
can't rely on authority
and you can't rely on tradition you
can't say well this is the way we always
did it
you know since the days of the greeks or
whatever middle ages you can't do that
because uh just as an example the 17th
century so-called scientific revolution
changed what existed until then which
was all these um
you know the greek notion of how to do
science
and the people in the 17th century
decided to change that they said no no
we're not going to do science like that
anymore now we're going to introduce
experiments okay
specifically and we're going to start
doing we're going to start testing
everything that we do all the
assumptions all the theories that we
have we're going to test them
and the way they did it they said let's
go to the lab and find out let's verify
if it's true
you know that's that's essentially what
they were up to
and once again yeah there's nothing you
can test no experiment you can run
uninvisible intangible entities okay so
if you have two magnets here right
okay
uh
it's intangible
it's invisible i can't see anything in
there you're not going to figure what's
in there in that region
by going to the lab
for that you need to go to your desk
you know dream a little visualize and
see how mother nature could be doing
that magic trick just like you would be
doing if you saw a magician on stage you
know cutting the lady in half or doing
some kind of magic trick there
and you say well how did he do that
well one way of doing it is you know the
first
attempt is you try to visualize how the
guy could have been doing it
now in the case of cutting the lady in
half you can reproduce it in the lab
what you cannot reproduce in the lab is
whatever's in there whatever is between
these two magnets okay the two black
round things there
that's that you're not going to discover
in the lab you're not going to discover
you know
uh if you drop the pencil okay falls to
the floor gravity right you're not going
to figure out what's here or here
by running an experiment the only way is
to visualize and try to you know
simulate it with some kind of object
that comes to your mind
so uh yeah none of those you can't use
those to define physics or science okay
and
again it's physics science the
definition right
it's not a matter of opinion
okay
you have to have a rational uh
definition that you can defend
okay so again the fact that we've been
doing science in a given way for the
last 400 years
that's tradition uh maybe
authority
maybe um
democracy the fact that people voted for
it
none of that counts
you gotta defend your definition of
science
okay so we we
here we're going to try to define what
science is okay
okay so um
one of the issues
that one of the ways to get to
what science is what physics is about
is by looking at what kind of questions
do people ask
what do people want to know what do they
want to understand what what is it that
you they want
anyone out there so-called physicists uh
scientists mathematical physicists
whatever
what do they want them to explain to
them
okay
and one good site is one where i write
and that's quora there's other sites you
know that do this question and answer
thing
but quora is one of them and quora
people go in there lay man whoever and
they ask questions they say look can you
answer this question for me
a lot of them are trivial and so on but
some of them get down to the
they agree to the basics and they said
how does a magnet work how does a magnet
attract another and how does gravity
work and so on how does light work
and they ask these questions here you
have uh the typical questions you'll
find out there okay
not
search subscribe to these but these are
questions you'll find in there for sure
in fact you'll find these same questions
in many
asked in different ways because they
just don't know how to ask them for
someone to get someone to answer them
and here what is light and what is light
made of and how do magnets uh repeal
what uh repeal away and attract each
other how do they work what is
electricity how does gravity work
these are types of questions people want
to understand they want you to explain
these things to them
and when they talk about explanations
you know they receive a um a
mathematical equation
or a
a reference a mathematical reference of
some kind from mathematical physicists
who go in there and try to answer some
of these questions they never receive a
mechanism
what people want to understand is you
know again a mechanism why does this
pencil
fall to the ground what's what's pushing
pulling it or pushing it to the ground
that's what people want to understand
and they never get that kind of answer
they say well look it falls at a rate of
9.8 meters per second square and there's
this field out there and
we've proven it and this experiments
over here
they talk about a lot of nonsense they
never get to the issue that was asked
and so people ask it in different ways
to see maybe someone
uh comes down to their level and
explains it to them
yeah and
you won't find it and so the the
question here the first question or one
of the first questions is is there a
difference between a description and an
explanation
between how and why
and usually when you use the word how
how does gravity work
well that can be interpreted in two ways
as a description as an
explanation
and so some people give them a
description thinking well i've asked
answer the question
and the person's asking for an
explanation
and a lot of people don't understand the
difference okay yeah an explanation
refers to causes
and a description does not address
causes
that's
the main point but the point is here
that we need to separate these two words
how and why because it confuses a lot of
people when people say when people say
why
uh people
one of the answers you'll find out there
well you keep asking why and and why and
why and why
and a lot of that refers to purpose and
reason
which has nothing to do with physics
it has to do with philosophy
and so people think that oh you're just
asking why and you just want to know
why is it like that
no that's not the issue the issue is
when people ask why they want to know
causes and mechanisms
so all i can do is separate how from why
i'm going to be using here today okay
how for descriptions and i'm not going
to use it for
explanations i'm going to use y for
explanations dealing with causes and
mechanisms not with purposes or reasons
okay
in the context of physics all why
related to reasons and purpose all have
the same answer because god said so
that's the answer to that one okay so
don't ask why in terms of
uh what was the purpose what was the
reason like if there was an intelligence
out there that created some kind of um
uh that set this in motion for some kind
of purpose
we're separating that so the why is
going to refer to causes and mechanisms
and the how
is going to refer to descriptions
okay
how why we're going to separate them
and here's some examples
okay
okay here's your how description okay
and again it's uh i'm gonna define it as
a typically chronological listing of
properties of b or behaviors that's what
the how related to description
uh
deals with okay
and there you have a couple examples the
red car crashed into the blue car at 50
miles per hour when the red car slid
down the street uh inclined to 30
degrees
and another one there the victim died of
respiratory failure at three o'clock two
hours after lunch
that was our descriptions you have not
explained causes mechanisms okay you
have to explain why
what otherwise well there are
explanations what is an explanation in
the context of physics okay
revealing the causes that underlie
mechanisms
okay
and so descriptions are not equal to
explanations a truck was towing the red
car down the street with a chain
okay
so you're pulling on a truck you're
pulling on the car and that's why the
car was going in that direction and
smashed against another car you're
giving a cause okay
and in the case of uh the victim that
died the victim died when alkaloids
entered her bloodstream and affected the
transmission of nerve impulses that
triggered respiratory failure okay so
one has to do with causes and mechanism
the other one is just a description of
you know the guy died at three o'clock
two hours after
uh eating lunch
okay so we want to separate house from
wise descriptions from explanations
and the problem we have today is that
all that comes out of mathematical
physics are descriptions
uh packaged as if they were explanations
and people think they got an explanation
they say oh i understood okay and leaves
he never got an explanation of the
mechanism so we don't have mechanisms
today we don't have causes today and
mathematician will tell you in your face
they cannot give you a cause they cannot
give you a mechanism and but people
never hear that
they say yeah they know it because
otherwise we wouldn't have technology
that's the answer that you're gonna get
okay how about uh how about physics okay
here's a couple physics issues okay
here's a description versus uh
explanation the gravitational field of
the sun known as curved space time is
the centripetal force that causes the
earth's almost circular orbit
that's a description so far the person
has not explained
the cause especially because they're
using field which is a concept it's not
a physical mechanism a field is not an
entity that you can tie a horse to okay
and then you have that other case there
if the electrons in each of the magnets
spin in the same direction you have a
strong magnetic field that produces
attraction
that's a description
so far we have no no understanding of
why the fact that electrons spinning
pull on each other how does how is it
that two electrons which are spinning in
the same direction
pull on each other
we need to find out uh
you know the mechanism of
how a magnet attracts to to is attracted
to another and you can't do it by saying
oh the electron spin
see this is the other way around what
they've done is they said look when a
magnet attracts another we notice we
measure we
detect that the electrons are spinning
in the same direction that's different
than saying that the electrons spinning
in the same direction cause or trigger
an uh magnet to
attract another those are two different
things okay and that's what we're going
to look at today
anyways here you see
a y
explanation okay for causes and
mechanism the centripetal force that
keeps the earth bound to the sun is
mediated by cables
now you might say well i don't believe
in cables i don't believe in chains you
know no problem we don't care we're
talking about a mechanism the person is
saying that the sun is attached to the
earth by cables and vice versa and so
now we can explain what that centripetal
centripetal force is
and then there you have uh for magnets
angels holding hands between two magnets
and pulling causes attractions
and you might say well i don't believe
in angels well nobody cares nobody cares
if you believe in angels the issue here
is
mechanism the person is explaining to
you his theory of how angels holding
hands pull two magnets together okay we
can understand that what we cannot
understand is a field doing that okay
fields don't
are concepts it's like saying love pulls
two magnets together no it doesn't work
that way you can't use love to pull two
magnets together you can use angels you
can use ropes you can use chains
whatever you know you can use an
elongated object between two magnets to
explain attraction you cannot use a
concept such as force or field or energy
to explain you know why a magnet or how
a magnet attracts another that's the
whole issue okay
okay uh so what we're trying to answer
again are the invisible stuff right
because the visible stuff
we've already figured out you you see
again i mentioned the other day you have
a cart and the cart moved from a to b
and so you asked the boy how did the
cart move from a to b he said oh very
simple
very simple i
brought my horse
tied the cart to the horse and i pulled
it across
and so you look at that and you say okay
i understood everything because you see
all the objects
but in the case of magnetism you know
you have this invisible whatever
and you can't see it you can't touch it
and so that's where people get stumped
and they say that mathematician gets
them they say well i don't see anything
i don't feel anything
so there's nothing there and because
there's nothing there then it's done by
magic
again angels have a better chance than
mathematics to do to explain some of
these phenomena
okay um
so here we begin with some of the
uh testimonies okay
and i brought a couple fellows some of
them you know
one
fellow's name is nick lucid
and he
has a program he has a youtube channel
uh the science asylum so i brought him
today to testify and another fellow
another
big bigger celebrity his name is derek
muller
and he's going to be testifying today as
well on my program okay
so um
let's hear what all these people have to
say about magnetism okay how a magnet
attracts another let's begin with one of
them okay all these
folks are on the internet so you can
find them there okay here's the first
one okay give me a second here
here it goes
pay attention how do magnets work a
magnet is just something normally metal
that has a particularly well organized
magnetic field in most objects the
natural state of these tiny magnetic
domains as they're called is essentially
random with their north poles pointing
in different directions the upshot being
in layman's terms that they cancel each
other out but in a magnet most or all of
these magnetic domains line up in the
same direction and rather than
cancelling each other out the tiny
magnetic fields combine to form a big
aligned magnetic field
okay so uh we have this field
whatever that field is and we have these
domains
is that what causes uh attraction
between two magnets we're gonna use
field and domains
i mean you can say that within a magnet
like this little red one uh round one
there you know
that sticks to this one you can say that
the
domains are aligned
great no problem
how does the alignment of that
pull on this one
that's what you got to answer and this
fellow says well it's the field well the
field is a concept field is just a bunch
of numbers you can't use the word field
to say that a magnet attracts another
because of the field or because the
domains are aligned
okay
let's look at another one here's another
fellow and he tries to explain
magnets again they all claim to
explain magnus how a magnet attracts
another how a magnet works or anything
along those lines okay and let's listen
to this fella okay here here he goes
listen carefully
if we truly want to know how a magnet
works we're going to have to zoom into
the quantum realm
as we all know electrons orbit around
the nucleus of the atom on specific
energy levels called electron shells
within each electron shells exist
subshells each subshell can hold up to
two electrons which have different spins
which is nothing but a fancy term for
the inherent angular momentum of an
electron usually in a pair of electrons
found in a subshell one electron has a
spin of up and the other electron has a
spin of down
the spin of the electron which is
believed to create a small magnetic
field which combined with the other
small magnetic fields from other
electrons can create one big magnetic
field which is powerful enough to
influence objects
okay
and again we get the same old same mole
it's either the fields
or it's the virtual photons or it's the
electrons spinning in the same direction
okay so here we have
two electrons okay this one belongs to
magnet a this one belongs to magnet b
and they're spinning in the same
direction
okay
in this case seen from above it's
counterclockwise
okay
so how does that
make this
electron attract that electron or this
magnet the one that this one belongs to
attract the magnet
this magnet here how does it achieve
that
thing through the distance
so the fact that
electrons spin
does not give me a mechanism of how a
magnet attracts another okay
and neither does the field which is a
concept
okay here's another fella okay you might
uh well listen to him he he probably
knows exactly how it happens okay
give me a second here put them on okay
testifying in an atom the rotation of
nucleus
and the revolution and rotation of
electrons indicates the flow of small
currents in them
this flow of current induces magnetic
moments
the resultant of all the magnetic
moments gives the net magnetic moment of
the atom
now if all the magnetic moments induced
in the material are in the same
direction
then the material behaves like a magnet
but if all the magnetic moments induced
in the material are in different
directions
then they cancel out each other and
their resultant becomes zero
in such cases the material does not
behave like a magnet atomic origin of
magnetism in any magnetic material can
be explained by taking into
consideration the magnetic moments of
the spinning and revolving electrons and
also that of the spinning nucleus
so what does the fact that the domains
are aligned and the
electrons are spinning how does that
produce attraction
where's the mechanism
again these are descriptions
presented as
mechanisms they're presenting the house
as wise
descriptions as explanations that's the
problem here and people say well he
explained it no he did not explain it he
described that two electrons spin and
that the
domains are aligned
that that doesn't explain the causes
uh you want to explain how the cart went
across you got to say well i tied a rope
to the cart and pulled on the car that
everybody can understand that but if you
say
how did the cart
cross the river
or get close to the other cart on the
other side of the river and the person
answers well the watermelons over here
were going
spinning clockwise and the ones over
here were also spinning clockwise
what kind of answer is that
how does that explain how one cart
went to the other side of the river and
got and hit the other cart the fact that
the watermelons on top of the carts were
spinning clockwise or counterclockwise
what does one thing have to do with
another
this is the issue okay
and uh these people think they're giving
you an explanation when they're not
they're giving you a description which
is packaged presented in the guise of
explanations
okay here's another this is from ucla
okay
university of california los angeles one
of the top universities on the planet
okay so
and this is guys a phd so here you're
talking about
major words okay here he goes okay
give me a second here let me put him on
one magnet either repels or attracts
another and nobody knows why
except you
after watching today's video
one way to understand magnets is through
magnetic domains
it was discovered that electrons had a
property called spin
that is the electron was spinning
as it circled the nucleus
it's the alignment of these electrons
spins that results in the magnetic
properties of iron these atoms have an
unusual double valence in which their
two valence electrons are paired with
parallel spins in summary a magnet is a
collection of microscopic crystal
domains that have their electron spins
aligned this is particularly prevalent
in iron nickel and cobalt in which there
is a pair of valence electrons with
their spins aligned
hot shot huh knows everything ucla phd
and what do you say that the electrons
spin
first of all the electrons don't spin
because what he did there you know
throwing that little twirl on the
electron that's not what spin is and all
mathematician will tell you that's not
what spin is
okay remember spin is a static concept
it's an orientation but he says they're
spinning like a and he
suggests that it's like a top
which is not spin at all in quantum
that's not the notion of spin in quantum
but that's how they presented that's why
they use the word spin
you know and so he says it's spinning
okay we'll concede so it's spinning and
how does the fact that this guy is
spinning clockwise and this guy is
spinning clockwise both of them spinning
clockwise or counterclockwise as seen
from the top right
how does this magnet attract this magnet
electron this electron belongs to magnet
a this electron belongs to magnet b
how does a magnet attract another
because these two are spinning
once again how does a cart attract
another because the watermelons in each
cart are spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise
makes no sense whatsoever what these
people are saying but they're saying oh
it spins
so what
it spins what's the mechanism so again
it's not an explanation it's not a why
it's not a mechanism what it is is a
description there's twist twisting it
around they're saying what's really
happening here is that every time a
magnet attracts another it turns out
that when they measure the fields are
going in the same direction they say
well it's the electrons that are
creating those fields so they're all
totally in the same direction
that still doesn't explain the mechanism
the fact that the electrons are spinning
in the same direction right it does not
explain the mechanism of attraction at a
distance from a distance okay now
if each of the electrons
were tied by i don't know by threads or
ropes or chains or cables to the other
electron and this one spins then yeah we
can imagine how it tugs on this one
because there's an elongated object
between them
then we can understand uh attraction but
to say that the two balls just spin
one over here and the other one over
there and they're isolated because
they're discrete particles
what have you said you haven't explained
the mechanism
okay uh here's uh my dear friend um
um nick lucid okay
and he's gonna testify here for us okay
here he goes
this is his explanation of how a magnet
works any electron with a non-zero
angular momentum will act like a tiny
magnet for each one that's in a
clockwise orbital there's another one
that's in a counterclockwise orbital
this single electron has an inherent
property called spin angular momentum
when you zoom back out to the atomic
level most of those electrons still pair
up and cancel because like charges repel
they get as far from each other as
possible and line up in the same
direction getting the loner electrons to
line up isn't enough you also have to
get nearby atoms to line up with each
other and then get enough regions of
atoms to line up we call those regions
domains
more of the same what do we have we have
domains what do we have electron spin
what do we have fields
uh there's also virtual photons by the
way we haven't gotten to that but
you know this is all nonsense none of
those are explanations for how a magnet
attracts another
so all these people who are phds okay
and they go out there and they
say tell you oh i'm gonna tell you how
a magnet works how a magnet attracts
something else
and what they give you is descriptions
they say i explained it didn't i
and no they haven't what they've done is
they made a description and they
presented it in the guise of an
explanation
okay so uh here's uh
another phone he does minute physics
okay
um
on youtube okay and
let's see what he has to say about
magnetic objects are able to magically
attract at long distances because they
generate magnetic fields that extend
invisibly out beyond the object
magnetism is a fundamentally quantum
property amplified to the size of
everyday objects
in order for an everyday object to be
magnetic though it has to have a unified
kingdom of magnetic domains each made up
of bajillions of magnetic atoms which
also need to be aligned with each other
each of which can only be magnetic in
the first place if it has an
approximately half-filled outer shell of
electrons so their intrinsic magnetic
fields can align and not cancel each
other out
so
did you understand how a magnet attracts
another
no of course not and and here's the
punchline to that comes from uh
fellow his name is derek muller and he
decided to testify in this program as
well and here's his testimony okay here
goes
where do magnetic fields come from a
magnetic field is just what an electric
field becomes when an electrically
charged object starts moving
particles with electric charge also
happen to be tiny magnets if you want to
know why they're tiny magnets well you
may as well ask why are particles
charged in the first place or why do
objects with mass and energy attract
each other gravitationally no one knows
we just know that's the way the universe
works
never ask a mathematician why
never because he says well all you're
doing is just asking why then you're
going to ask another why and why is this
why is that why is the other thing
no the first why is causes and mechanism
whatever comes after that
is not a why question related to physics
99 of the time what comes after that is
a why related to purpose and reason why
did god make it that way why is the
speed of light 300 000 kilometers per
second
that's a that's an irrational question
to present in physics
okay that's assuming that you're already
assuming that there's an intelligence
out there god for example and he
waved his magic wand and said i'm gonna
make the speed of light little c three
hundred thousand kilometers per second
why because he had a headache that day
that's the why for that no we don't care
about that we're talking about a
mechanism and these people are skipping
the mechanism say well you just keep
asking why and why and why no we want to
have just one wine we want a mechanism
you point to the mechanism we understand
it
you know again uh the fact that you say
that two watermelons roll in the same
direction that doesn't explain the cause
so it's a proper question to ask why how
did one cart get attracted to another
because the watermelons are spilling
spinning
you know on top of the cart
so this is the issue the issue is that
the question of why meaning causes
mechanisms where you want an explanation
that's a rational question now if the
guy then later on says but why does the
electron spin
that's an irrational question
that's an irrational question
if if you're referring to purpose and
reason
okay now there could be a cause a
physical mechanism that triggers the
electron to spin that's something else
that's something you could answer within
physics but if you're just talking about
purpose and reason like why does it spin
who made it spin who who decided that
should spin then you're talking about an
irrational question
so you have to be careful with a white
question what are you addressing are you
addressing physics or uh you know are
you trying to prove your god that god
some intelligence out there cr you know
set the world in motion in a certain way
and that's the
that's the reason the purpose that he's
got a purpose for all this that's
separate that's got nothing to do with
physics okay so
uh the questions that you ask have to be
related to physics in order to be
rational
okay
[Music]
here are some of the
responses you get in quora because you
heard all these phds and they couldn't
answer anything and you get the same
thing in quora and and i only picked
people who are professionals or who
claim to be professionals okay uh i
don't know them so i can't say but we're
going to assume that they're telling the
truth and this is what they had to say
okay
and yeah one though he says if two
electrons spin in the same direction it
costs energy to keep them close to each
other and if you stop supplying the
energy they drift apart so it's a
question of energy right opposite spin
electrons have no problem sharing the
same space
okay sharing the same space you mean
they superimpose
in the case of iron uh each atom has
four unpaired electrons which can accept
opposite spin electrons into the same
space with no constant energy supply
this makes them highly reactive to other
materials with unpaired electrons so far
he has not explained how one magnet
attracts another okay the fact that
electrons are spinning again it's uh the
watermelon spin spinning on top of the
cart
and the other guy he's a professor of
physics okay let's see what he has to
say every electron is a magnetic dipole
okay with an associated magnetic field
again we have the
uh
already saying that electrons are
magnetic it's got a field running around
it which is just a bunch of numbers okay
so we don't a magnetic field is just
values uh strength that's all it is so
we don't have a physical object and he
says in certain solids and he mentions a
couple there there is not only an
unpaired electron there are also short
range forces between atoms that align
the magnetic moments of those unpaired
electrons to produce a fairly large
region a magnetic domain in which all
moments point in roughly the same
direction
has he explained how a magnet attracts
another has he explained
the cause absolutely not oh they're
saying they're giving you a description
and they're answering questions at
people asking quora related to
mechanisms
they want to have an explanation for how
a magnet attracts another this is what
you get
here's another fellow also in quora okay
again all these are supposedly
professional people okay
photons that are passed between bodies
without the possibility of being
observed are called what virtual photons
what is a virtual photon it's a magical
uh
particle it's a particle that appears at
the end of a magic wand whenever the
mathematician needs to explain something
he introduces the virtual photon means
which means that immediately it
disappears out of this universe it
appears only to make the equation come
out right or his explanation come out
right that's what a virtual photon is
says these virtual photons can form
virtual photo currents that try to
minimize the energy squeezed into the
field at any point of concentration that
is how magnets work
yeah no kidding any two magnets are
exchanging virtual photo currents which
tend to minimize the energy trapped in
the local field if placed with their
post north to south and the magnets are
moved closer together the energy in the
field is minimized if one magnet is
turned three 180 degrees and pushed
together the force required to push them
together is delivered to the external
field by making the virtual photo
currents more intense each virtual
photon represents a unit of energy again
uh this is all nonsense this is
poppycock hasn't explained absolutely
anything talking about virtual photons
which are magical particles that appear
again at the whim of the mathematicians
and then talking about energy and fields
and
those are all abstract concepts we need
to find out what physical object brings
two magnets together that's what is the
mechanism
and if you say there's
nothing there because you can't see or
touch it you are in effect doing black
magic you're saying that this one
attracts that one uh by way of concepts
fields particles that are not particles
uh forces which are not
things
energy
concept
how does this one attract that one so
you need to explain the mechanism
and of course they cannot explain that
mechanism that's the problem why because
they can't see or touch the mediators
and because they can't see or touch them
they say there's nothing there
well then are you going to do action at
a distance with
magic
if there's nothing there you're doing it
with magic that's what you're saying the
world the universe works with magic
okay this is what you're
defaulting to when you don't put an
object in there okay
okay uh here's a
another fellow quora okay
says uh spin angular momentum is an
inbuilt property of electrons again all
that spin stuff right this spin it makes
me spin the spin can take only two
values
plus one and minus one and if the
electron is spin up it produces a
magnetic field in a particular direction
and a spin down electron produces it the
other way great so uh the fact that
they're spinning one goes away and the
other one comes towards why do we know
why
all he did was describe and say you know
whenever it spins we notice that they
come together that's all he's saying he
he's not explaining why the spinning
causes one magnet to attract another
and another
says here sometimes people explain the
effect of the magnetic field in terms of
virtual photons this is frankly not help
not very helpful so this guy
is debunking what the other guy said he
said no no he's wrong
we don't do it with virtual photons okay
so what do you do it with it is much
better to explain the attraction or
repulsion between magnets as due to the
magnetic field
okay and now you introduce the field of
concept rather than in terms of emission
of particles okay excitations of the
electromagnetic field are called photons
but these are nothing like classical
particles they are what excitations in
other words they're verbs he's saying
that excitations
is is what's going to produce attraction
so they're talking about fields which
are concepts bunch of numbers
values and then he says it's excited it
it waves it vibrates
and because it vibrates somehow whatever
the mechanism is you know it produces
the attraction between two magnets and
please don't use virtual photons or
photons at all now we're going to use
fields concepts
yeah again you know what these people
are doing is magic because they're
trying to explain this with magic
they're saying with concepts and that is
magic it reduces to black magic you're
saying that a magnet attracts another
because of love or because intelligence
or because of data
that you collected
you know
how does that explain the mechanism
and that's where we're that's where all
these people fail but it's interesting a
couple of the other uh
answers that
people gave in quora and these are very
interesting because they show you where
they really stand okay these guys say
better
first guys the answer is virtual photons
being a mathematical convenience i would
call them questionable of questionable
existence rather than invisible okay so
this fellow doesn't believe in virtual
photons because he says it's just a
mathematical convenience what does the
other file say it says it's pretty clear
from the answers given here
and there were like 40 answers at least
in one of these questions
that the actual answer is that no one
knows how magnets work
i had a career which involved the design
of transformers which completely rely on
magnetism for their operation and i
certainly do not know how they work
one guy said it truthfully okay yeah
they don't know how magnets work when
you go to the university they don't
teach you how magnets work because the
authorities the people who teach
never learned or never figured it out
and all they do is parrot what their
previous teachers told them which
parroted what the previous teacher told
them so it's just a succession of
ignoramuses who pass
uh this
non-knowledge this
you know this um
notion that
i like that electrons spin or that feels
uh mediate attraction or that virtual
photons mediate attraction all these
people all they do is just pass on from
one generation to the other and they
have no mechanism so this fellow's right
you know no one knows how they work
okay so let's get it right these people
have no explanation not a single person
out there who has a video on youtube not
a single person who answers in quora can
tell you how a magnet attracts another
and they put how a magnet works how a
magnet attracts another it's nonsense
they cannot tell you okay
and uh the first thing you have to
realize that faraday and maxwell who
studied fishy faraday who studied magnus
quite a bit he said there's got to be a
physical object in there in that place
we call field remember he's the guy who
invented the word field okay
and he said you know after studying
magnus first half his life
he said you know there's got to be
something in that region we call field
there's something in motion in there
okay here are the testimonies of these
two individuals
in the case of faraday he says i cannot
conceive curved lines of force without
the conditions of a physical existence
in that intermediate space
and what did maxwell say he says field
the space in the neighborhood of the
electric and magnetic bodies in that
space there is matter in motion
so both of these people both of these
individuals they said there's something
there those lines of force are not
abstract
and the so-called field is not an
abstraction there's a there's matter in
motion an exotic type of matter
obviously but it's matter in motion so a
field is something that is moving in
other words inside the field there is
something that is moving the field may
be static you know if you have a if you
throw iron filings
uh on top of
a magnet
they line up and they form the typical
patterns okay that you see maybe on a
piece of paper or whatever
but and so you say well there's nothing
moving anymore everything just bare you
know all the iron filings are glued to
the magnet so in that sense there's
nothing moving
but what these two people are saying
they're telling you okay
is that even though the iron filings are
not moving
the magnetic field is something that has
is made out of something that is in
motion there's some exotic matter in
motion in what we call the magnetic
field
that's the issue there's something there
you can't see it you can't touch it
because something is not that which you
can see or touch something is that which
has shape and in the case of magnetism
light and uh
you know gravity
you can't see or touch the mediators
so
see and touch are the wrong criteria to
define the word object the word thing
okay
okay so um
this is how we do it in science uh at
least here okay we explain a mechanism
and for that first we have to show you
what is inside that field that both
faraday and maxwell said there is matter
in mo there's something moving in there
in that so-called field
the iron filing stays stand still but
the field is moving something is moving
in the field okay and uh the fact that i
showed uh in the past that
um
underwater
magnets attract one iron filing at a
time show you that there is something in
motion in that so-called region we call
field okay
and so this is what we propose okay
we're saying that
field is a
made out of all these threads that are
sweeping around they're swinging around
atoms okay that's what we call a field a
magnetic field is comprised of swinging
threads
and electricity consists of spinning
merged electron shells we have rows of
electron shells uh typically at the
molecular level and those form the
so-called domains of a magnet when
they're aligned uh the
threads that are swinging around they
sweep in the same direction and now you
have what is known as a field a magnetic
field
okay so that's what we're proposing okay
now you say well you know i don't
believe in your threads i don't believe
that there are threads sweeping around
this is not a question of belief it's a
question of making an assumption you
have to make an assumption
regarding an invisible intangible entity
in fact
everybody has done to this day so
it must be news to you but everybody's
been using particles for the last 2000
years
and they say there are particles there
they do everything with particles they
simulate them with particles did you ask
them if there are really particles er
forming a magnetic field
i mean and let's concede you say there
are particles okay show me how you
attract with those particles show me how
you repel with those particles show me
the mechanism if you're going to do with
particles
but everybody has made the assumption
that the region called field
is filled with particles
and we're saying no it's not particles
not discrete particles we have swinging
threads
it's an assumption just like particles
no different than particles so when you
say bill
uh i don't believe in your part in your
threads no problem do you believe in
particles
and if you believe in particles where
did you get that wasn't that an
assumption or did you see and touch the
particles inside a magnetic field
so yeah you have to make an assumption
no matter what you can't escape the
assumption no matter what okay
okay so what did this fellow say the um
critic
who criticized my videos
he talked about green green pixies he
said well you know i can also put green
pixies in there
okay
so i didn't know really what a green
pixie was you know i mean who knows what
it is maybe he's talking about little
particles or maybe who knows what you
know and so i looked it up i'm saying
let's see what a green pixie is okay
officially
okay so we look up green pixie and we
find this okay
uh here you have uh these little green
pixies on the left that look like
leprechauns or uh
uh you know little gnomes
and then you have the green pixies on
the right which are like particles these
are the two things that i found out
there
uh maybe there are other versions i mean
i don't know he would have to this fella
would have to specify what he means by a
green pixie but those are the ones that
i found okay so i'm gonna
simulate
uh his stuff with green pixies okay
let's find out if the green pixies that
he says that yeah he can come up with
green pixies okay let's see if we can
explain magnetism with green pixies
we'll conceive let's assume there are
green pixies no problem okay we're
looking at mechanisms here let's find
out he can do it with green pixies
okay here we have um
uh one way of doing this i didn't do it
with the green pixies i replaced them
with gingerbread men because i just want
to show you the mechanism that you can
explain with green pixies you can
explain the traction and here you see it
okay we have these green gingerbread men
you can replace them with pixies as you
want i thought it was better to do it
with uh gingerbread men because they're
usually you know put in series and
holding hands and so on and i said well
you can explain with this if you want to
replace them with pixies no problem okay
so we can explain it with uh these
gingerbread men
uh we can also do it with angels you
know they're magical too you know here's
two angels pushing two magnets one
towards the other maybe that's how
magnetism is done
uh can you understand the mechanism of
course you can because you can see the
angels pushing the magnets towards each
other okay so you say yeah i understand
the mechanism
now you say well i don't believe in
angels that's irrelevant we don't care
we're we're trying to understand the
mechanism this guy is proposing the guy
is saying there's angels pushing the
magnets together or maybe maybe they're
pulling them you know maybe the angels
are on the inside pulling the magnets
together
the important thing here is do you
understand the mechanism that's the
important part okay
and uh how do you push them apart well
again that's how
repulsion works you know we can put the
angels in between and it works okay we
understand the mechanism we're saying
that angels are pushing the magnets
apart
and
they could also be pulling them apart
okay so maybe that's how repulsion works
so we can explain with green pixies
meaning you know leprechauns gnomes
angels gingerbread men we can explain
uh attraction and repulsion if we put
them in there okay you would understand
the mechanism
okay so if you put these guys in there
we can explain the mechanism
do you believe in green pixie do you
believe in leprechauns you believe in
angels and unicorns we don't care
that's separate
we're trying to understand the mechanism
that the guy is explaining
okay and it's a little better than the
two spinning electrons the the
watermelons spinning in two different
carts we don't understand the mechanism
there here we understand the mechanism
okay so you may not like angels you may
not like pixies but you understand the
mechanism do you believe it that's
suffering that you deal with that in
church on sundays uh sunday school you
know you talk to your priest about
belief here we talk about mechanisms
okay so let's get that right we're
looking at mechanisms only we understand
the pixie mechanism if the pixies are a
little green men of some kind you know
angels or leprechauns or whatever so we
understand it let's look at the other
one the
little green particles okay if those are
the pixies he was referring to okay so
here let's see
there you have them you have the
pixies the green pixies between two
magnets
please explain attraction with your
green pixies how does it attract how
does it repulse
i mean here i'm i'm putting the pixies
in there y'all i'm not allowing you to
put the pixies what are these if you say
the pixies are a bunch of loose
particles okay fine please explain
attraction with your green pixies
see this is the problem you cannot
explain it with your green pixies if
pixies are a bunch of particles
and that's the issue the issue is you
can explain it with angels better than
you can with little particles
so no do not uh
now you know they they have this other
version the casimir effect where you
have uh particles pushing on the outside
if you remove the ones in the inside
yeah and then how do you produce uh
repulsion then
you put them back in and push the
magnets apart you know who's putting how
do you put them and get out what's the
mechanism for putting particles in for
taking particles out between two magnets
i mean are you saying that somehow
uh the magnet knows that i'm going to
remove the particles between and whoop
they stick to each other
but this is very simple very very simple
take two magnets don't take my word for
it just do it at home do it on your own
okay
take two magnets okay like i'm doing
here two simple magnets okay so that you
get the
the real basics okay
and you can see that they're being
pulled from the inside
i mean i hold them and i don't feel any
push from the outside nothing's pushing
on my hands the tug is from the inside
okay
so if you're going to do a casimir
effect then you're you're obviously an
irrational individual because
it's not like you're removing the
particles from between the magnets and
you have something the particles from
the outside pushing in that's not what's
happening here what you feel here is a
tug from the inside it's it's tugging on
my on the magnets from the inside that's
what it's doing
so there's something here which is
pulling on that magnet
that you cannot see or touch
okay
and you may say what's a field well you
got to identify what's inside the field
you got to tell me what the field is
made out of what's happening in that
field you say in the field you haven't
said anything that's like saying that's
x in there okay so it's x what's x
you know draw it for me show me show me
what it looks like okay
and what are you going to draw a field
all by itself
okay
and again it's got to be in motion
because you know um both uh faraday and
maxwell said there's matter in motion
inside a field whether you like it or
not so if you don't put something in
there
you're doing you know concepts again
you're doing black magic okay uh so how
do we do it in science okay we don't do
it with green pixies we do it with
threads and here's the mechanism and
hopefully you can understand the
mechanism just by watching you can see
what we're proposing
okay so uh
here we go okay here's uh
uh attraction okay if we turn the magnet
around sideways
nothing changes you still have
attraction
only when you turn it up uh in the
north south direction and you can see
now we went from clockwise to
counterclockwise now you have repulsion
and here it goes one more time okay
that's attraction okay
and again attraction
and now you have repulsion as soon as
you have clockwise versus
counterclockwise on the top for example
okay
so that's the mechanism what we're
saying is
the threads are moving that's that's
what a field is a bunch of threads which
are sweeping around in that region we
called magnetic field
and
you might say well you don't believe in
threads
and again we don't care
it's irrelevant we make an assumption
about what's in that region known as
field and we're saying that it's not
particles which is what the official
version is we're saying it's threads
that are swinging around
field is made of threads swinging around
countless threads that are swinging
around
and again we we just are interested in
you understanding the mechanism
and it's a rational mechanism because
you can see how
uh attraction occurs and how uh
repulsion occurs and here it is one more
time look at the mechanism that's all
we're interested in and i use my two
little
fellows axel and rod
and you can see how they're swinging
their ropes they're they're their
jumping rope and just look at the
direction of the ropes and it'll give
you an idea how a magnet attracts and
repels another magnet the mechanism okay
look at the mechanism here they are
okay
both on the top are clockwise if you
turn it sideways nothing changes you
have counterclockwise counterclockwise
only when you turn one around and have
clockwise versus counterclockwise do the
ropes clash and push each other away on
the bottom and on the top but when you
have it in this direction
counterclockwise and counterclockwise at
the top
well they attract why because the ropes
latch into each other
and if you turn it around nothing
changes
so we explain what we observe with two
magnets
okay very simple the mechanism do you
believe in ropes we don't care if you do
or not okay it's irrelevant to the
question that we have here we're trying
to figure out how a magnet works okay
and what we're saying is a magnet this
is the mechanism of how a magnet works
when they both go in in the same
direction okay on the top
and also on the bottom the two bottom
ones go in the same direction the two
top ones go in the same direction the
threads and so they latch on to each
other and they pull that's what we're
saying and when you turn the magnet
around now they clash
and now they push each other away so it
explains it simulates what happens to
two magnets
and anyone who says opposite is simply
just plain hard to get that's all he's
doing his religion went down the drain
so he doesn't like you saying that you
know his he is an irrational individual
yeah we have a mechanism
whether you believe in that mechanism we
don't care we're showing you a mechanism
of how two magnets work
and you can't do that with your green
pixies meaning the particles you can do
it with angels better with than with
particles which is what the
establishment uses it's the
establishment which uses green pixies
meaning particles and they cannot do it
with particles that's what we've been
simulating all these invisible
intangible phenomena for the last i'd
say at least 2500 years
okay
okay but does it stop there uh
no we're saying not only can they not
explain magnetism
it turns out that you know the
establishment cannot explain gravity
i mean we've known about gravity since
since man had use of reason
i mean since i guess the paleolithic
i mean you people noticed that if they
dropped the stone i guess the caveman
dropped the stone or let go of a stone
it always fell to earth it never fell to
the sky
and a lot of people must have wondered
about that throughout history you know
at some point people say why does it
always fall to the ground why does it
always fall on my foot this this stone
and of course they never had an
explanation for that why because they
could not see or touch the mediator of
gravity
that's the big problem if you can't see
or touch it
then you say well i have no explanation
and the explanation is very simple very
very simple you just have to make the
invisible visible once you make it
visible then it's a piece of cake
and again you know if uh if i just show
you the stone in the earth and let go of
the stone and the stone falls to earth
you don't understand the mechanism
but if i make the mediators visible
now you understand the mechanism now
whether you believe that those are the
mediators mother nature uses that's a
separate issue that's in a question of
belief
but right now we're trying to explain
the mechanism okay the why not the how
but the why okay
okay and um
what the establishment does in fact what
this individual who criticized the
videos believes in is that he thinks we
have an explanation in space time that
you know the mathematician came up with
all these years
uh with space time and they say well
that explains
why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system it explains many things
okay and he said it explains mercury in
other words he it explains he said the
orbit of mercury meaning that
um
there is no planet vulcan between
mercury and the sun which is what people
speculated on that maybe that was the
case
and yeah they solved that problem
there's no planet vulcan but
it created
bigger problems like i showed the other
day in the fact that you know the it
doesn't explain the um
the way the direction in which the uh
canvases the fishnets of space-time
point in the case of oberon the uh
moon of uh
uranus and in the uh case of uh sharon
which is the moon of pluto
in the case of oberon you know you have
oberon going towards the sun
and in the case of sharon you have it
this bullseye pattern as seen from the
sun
and
and the earth you know weighs it down
together
like parallel with the ecliptic and so
these three have different orientations
for the fishnets you cannot explain that
with einstein's theory okay but you
gotta look at the previous video of
pictures worth a thousand words
okay uh so here we start out on the
wrong foot because we have stephen
hawking and he was a prominent uh
mathematician mathematician mathematical
physicist as they call him um that
recently died and this is what he has to
say about space-time okay he says uh an
event is something that happens at a
particular point in space and at a
particular time it is often helpful to
think of the four coordinates of an
event as specifying its position in a
four-dimensional space called space-time
it is impossible to imagine a
four-dimensional space
well that's a terrible way to start a
presentation he's going to give us a
physical interpretation he's going to
say that objects slide
or roll on this fishnet he calls
space-time but he begins by telling you
that there's no way you can even imagine
a four-dimensional space in other words
the thing that he's going to use to
create gravity
uh why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system you know what what physical
entity prevents it he he says it's
space-time but you i cannot imagine it
for you no one can imagine
so he's telling you right up front that
he's not going to give you a physical
interpretation you say you can't imagine
it but just believe it
no kidding
okay um
here's uh
you probably look at the nice sky if
you've got a telescope
and you'll see andromeda galaxy
okay and it's pretty far away you know
it's
you know
you got to look for it okay it's not
around the corner out there in the night
sky and here's a picture of that the one
on the left is uh andromeda the guy on
the right is uh the milky way galaxy
okay uh so there you have them uh
labeled
and so it's pretty far away okay the
andromeda galaxy from from
earth right from our galaxy
and it just to give you a sense of the
uh sizes of what you're staring at here
here you have the
andromeda galaxy and it's 220
000
220 000 light years in diameter so if
you go from one uh edge to the other of
this galaxy
it would take you
220 000 years if you travel at the speed
of light okay
in comparison
just the earth which is a little tiny
dot invisible dot in the one on the
right in the milky way
it takes
0.04 second
four hundredths of a second
to go at the speed of light from one
side of the planet to the other
and here to go through the galaxy this
entire galaxy
220 000
light years
big distance
and so what is the distance between our
galaxy and the andromeda galaxy well
it's uh two and a half
million light years away
two and a half million light years away
so you're talking about enormous
distances
you know and uh
why is that more or less important well
we're looking at the
light
you know in under the rope model you
know we're going to find out that
the ropes stretch all the way from here
to there
that's going to be the argument okay
so so what does it have to travel well
if you travel at the speed of light from
here to andromeda or vice versa it's two
and a half million
years if you travel at the speed of
light
now andromeda is
coming towards us that means there's
gravity between the milky way and
andromeda galaxy whatever gravity is
somehow we're pulling on
uh the andromeda galaxy or the andromeda
galaxy is pulling on us
and so we're getting closer and closer
together and they call it they say it's
gravitational gravitational pull it's
very slow uh compare you know for these
distances you're talking about something
very very slow uh the speed is 400 000
kilometers per hour as some people
calculated and that would mean that
anywhere between two to three billion
years that's what it would take for
these two galaxies to collide
okay at the speed that they're going
now
and here's a simulation of that okay you
can see that uh the two galaxies
uh coming together after two to three
billion years okay and forming a bigger
galaxy
here it starts again okay
this is more or less what they
envisioned would happen
uh in two to three billion years okay
they hit it a couple times until they
finally form a single galaxy i guess a
bigger galaxy okay so this is this is
the notion that they have that our
galaxy are coming together meaning
gravity whatever gravity is okay
is pulling them together
action at a distance they call it
so what is pulling
um
andromeda to us or us to andromeda if it
is pulling
that's one issue the other issue is
hold it uh are you saying that um
light travels
like a little ball or a little wave
from there to here that's why we can see
the andromeda galaxy it travels two
and a half
million uh years in other words uh at
the speed of light
when it reaches our eye it traveled two
and a half million years without hitting
anything just straight to our eyes
you know uh and you're
whenever you talk in terms of what's
happening in the universe
you're talking about astronomical
quantities that's the point that i'm
trying to make here anything is
outside our everyday experience okay so
keep that in mind okay so um how does
something attract something else from a
distance well i like to point out to mr
richard miller he's a professor at uh
berkeley and this is what he has to say
about how atoms pull on atoms okay he
says uh that there's a big mess here and
he shows the
the earth that's big m there
and that's little u that's sitting on
the planet okay that's earth supposedly
the big mass and uh you're the little
mass and he says there's this big mass
here and you have you with your little
mass here every atom on earth is pulling
on every atom of you you're also pulling
on it
the amazing thing about gravity is that
it goes right through things
so let's see uh if i'm pulling on every
atom of earth and every atom of earth is
pulling on me and here we have the
andromeda galaxy and every atom in our
galaxy is pulling on every atom of the
andromeda galaxy and the andromeda
galaxy every atom there is pulling on
every atom
of
uh the milky way
then uh we're talking about an elongated
entity that's stretching all the way
from the andromeda galaxy all the way to
us and us all the way to the andromeda
galaxy
every atom there is bound to every atom
here and every atom here is bound to
every atom there
and you know when they talk about
entanglement they say it doesn't matter
how far two particles are
one influences the other instantaneously
if this one is rolling clockwise and the
other one is
rolling counterclockwise immediately
when this one is turned around in the
opposite direction that one instantly
turns in the opposite direction they
call it entanglement
and so again if one atom here
is turning clockwise it means that
the one
to which it's entangled
in the andromeda galaxy it's turning the
opposite way
so they're connected
so far we're talking about connections
we're talking about this atom being
connected to that atom and we're talking
about
the pull of gravity and they're saying
that that atom is attached it's bound
it's being pulled by an atom here
how do you pull if you don't have a
mediator how do you pretend to pull
magic
are you going to say that
it is so that's it
and so the question is you have to put a
physical object in there
that's the issue and you can't do it
without an object
and so here we this is the way we
explain
[Music]
this attraction this poll we're saying
that
the one atom in the andromeda galaxy is
bound to one atom here
in our region
in this case we can say it's the earth
which is part of the
part of our galaxy okay we're saying
they're connecting you say how can they
be connected
you're saying that the
rope which is what we're saying this
connection is that a rope-like mechanism
extends
uninterruptedly from over there to over
here
yeah that's exactly what i'm saying
that uh there is a connection
directly from one atom in the andromeda
galaxy to us
and you see that's impossible how can
that possibly be
well uh
let's see what particles let's find out
here's particles
uh are you saying that these particles
travel two and a half million
years at the speed of light from there
to here isn't that awesome
you know i mean is this believable
that this little particle travels from
here there and our particle travels from
here to there
and then the problem here is also that
yeah you can
maybe explain light with this can you
explain gravity with this can you send
particles from the andromeda galaxy to
us or us to them
and produce pull
that one atom here pulls on an atom over
there
please explain it please explain it with
this one-way mechanism of particles
going in one direction only
okay
now maybe you don't like particles maybe
you like waves which is actually the
same thing because those waves that you
see there those are made out of
particles i mean what is it that is
waving
and so again it's one-way mechanism so
even if you say well these are
gravitational waves okay so their waves
are going in one direction how does
andromeda pull on us by sending waves at
this abstraction this transverse wave in
one direction
so this is what you gotta explain you
gotta explain okay so there's your wave
i can see your wave or your particle or
whatever and the question is if it's
sending these waves in one direction how
does that pull on us in their direction
okay and yeah if you want a unified
theory you would have to unify light
with gravity you got the light part
assuming if we concede okay so light is
transverse waves they're going from
andromeda to us how does that pull on us
how does that produce gravity where's
the unified theory that you can come up
with using this model
that's the issue okay
and on the other hand let's do it with a
rope and again we're just going to show
one just like we showed only one wave
here we're going to show only one rope
okay
and here it is okay so we're saying that
there is a physical object that looks
like a rope dna like rope and it's
connected from one atom there to one
atom here obviously extremely thin
unimaginably
thin okay
but
the mechanism is what we're showing here
here you see light which is torsion of
the rope and you see gravity which is
you know one thing one atom pulling on
another okay so now you can explain both
the pull of gravity and the the speed of
light okay or or why light is a torsion
okay so you can explain both light and
gravity with this mechanism you cannot
do that with particles and you cannot do
that with transverse waves okay
so how do they uh do it in
general relativity how does this file
uh
explain well he says he's got an
explanation the explanation is space
time we do it all with space time well
first of all hawking already says that
uh space time is unimaginable it's a
concept it's four dimensional that's why
they say it's unimaginable okay but
let's concede all that let's grant it no
problem
show me the mechanism show me how
space-time
attracts andromeda to the milky way
okay now we're talking a long distance
here okay
okay so let's look at it let's find out
what it looks like here's andromeda
galaxy and us
uh each one
on this fishnet known as space time okay
that stretches all the way from over
there to over here
okay great okay we can say okay now we
can see why they're attracted to each
other because they both slide along
space-time which is the mechanism that
general relativity illustrates for
attraction between these two galaxies
great so far so good but we forgot
something let's let's uh first put the
uh fishnets underneath each one of the
galaxies remember each galaxy is also
pushing space down locally
around themselves that's why the stars
don't fly out so they have their own
fishnets
aside from this fishnet that extends all
the way from over there to over here
okay
but we're not done yet let's uh unfocus
let's take the telescope a little
further back so that we can see a bigger
picture of the universe okay
and so here we are gonna look at the
two galaxies from afar okay
uh we're gonna see a bigger
field of view now so they're smaller and
the stars are getting smaller because
we're seeing it from farther away or uh
unfocused
so to speak our
our
telescope okay but uh oh i guess i made
an error here because i i forgot
something you know i gotta
put the other galaxies that are in the
region now that you know now that we're
uh pulling the telescope outwards you
know so that we see more of the sky and
now we should see more galaxies okay
so this is what you would see something
along those lines
but again i guess i screwed up again
because you know i i should have put out
all the
fish nets that each one of these has you
know each one uh is pushing the uh local
space time downwards in its region okay
so
sorry about that i screwed up
uh but it turns out i i keep screwing up
i've got a bigger problem here because
now i gotta superimpose upon this the
universal
fishnet okay so not only is each one of
these galaxies pushing down
on the on its local fishnet but on top
of that we have the universal fishnet
because all these galaxies at least in
the local group seem to be coming
uh coming together and if uh general
relativity has its way they explain this
by saying there's this enormous fishnet
that is pulling all these everybody
sliding along this fishnet coming
together that's how they would explain
gravity okay
but uh i guess i'm not done yet because
this is just a local group now let's
look at it at a wider scale okay now we
have all these local groups and they're
all falling on this bigger
universal fishnet
it's getting pretty complicated here you
know i mean jesus christ uh
i i really feel sorry for for our poor
old god because he's got to manage all
this you know
uh we have fishnet on top of fishing it
on top of fishnet we got a bunch of
fishnets here and are they saying this
is how gravity works
uh you know you know i feel sorry for
god he's got to manage this this fishnet
universe that we have of relativity we
have the local
galaxies um
they're falling on their own local
fishnet then all the fishnets are
falling towards other fishnets
and i haven't done you know i mean i can
continue this forever
i mean the universe is pretty big
so are they saying this is how the
universe runs fishing it on top of
fishing it on top of fishing it on top
of fishnet
is this this the way gravity runs
yeah a little cumbersome much easier to
say that all atoms are physically
interconnected in the universe and
that's clean cut not only does it
explain light
torsion of light along this dna-like
entity but it
produces the attachment the binding that
we need between atoms
okay so we can explain light and gravity
the unified theory with the just by
changing the assumptions we don't have
to make assumptions on particles which
is what mathematical physics does we do
it with this entity that uh we call the
rope electromagnetic rope that binds any
two atoms and which atoms are made of
the same rope so there's no attachment
like you know it's not
taped with glue or anything you know
it's like the same thread that forms the
rope also forms the
atom to which uh the the where the rope
ends okay so one turns into the other
essentially
okay
uh so yeah uh this is the model okay
we're saying that's what's happening
between two galaxies no space time no
bending of space time which is a concept
unimaginable concept we're saying
there's a physical object okay it looks
like a rope and it binds any two atoms
in the universe okay do you believe in
it well we don't care
we don't care because science is not
about belief science is about
making an assumption of what's in the
invisible intangible world of mother
nature father universe i guess in this
case and
and with it explaining gravity light
magnetism and all the other invisible
intangible phenomena that we see out
there
okay so here's the uh conclusion uh for
today okay uh the so-called scientific
what we call the mathematical actually
mathematical method
inherited from the 17th century
meaning experiments that's the
ingredient they put in there does not
address the questions laymen want
answered laymen ask and want to
understand causes and mechanisms
the mathematical method has no success
in explaining invisible intangible
phenomena
okay that's the situation today no
mathematician alive today can explain
how a magnet attracts another no
mathematician today uh can explain how
gravity works and again we're talking
about causes and mechanism what's
causing uh gravity what's causing uh
magnetism and by that i don't mean
purpose and reason i mean what is the
physical cause okay that's what we're
asking the mathematical method doesn't
even address the issues uh and or
questions that layman won't answer and
you can see with the answers given in
quora for magnetism at least that you
don't get an answer you simply do not
have an answer in fact they'll confess
that they do not have an answer
and the reason all invisible mechanisms
of mathematicians are irrational is that
they simulate every phenomenon with
discrete particles and concepts that's
the problem we have to get rid of the
particle hypothesis there are no
discrete particles in the universe and
that's where the error is if you're
going to try to explain gravity or
you're going to try to explain magnetism
using discrete particles you're going to
have a hard time and at the end of the
story you would say well we don't
understand it of course you don't and
you're going to understand it even less
if you're going to simulate it with
concepts like field energy or force or
time
so even less you're going to understand
it
and that's the situation today so
science is not a process of study or of
accumulation of knowledge or it's not
even a process okay science is
exclusively rational explanations you
have to explain a mechanism
that's what science is about and that's
the definition we have to have of
science because that's what that's what
people ask that's what they want to
understand that's what they want to know
they want to know
how gravity works they want to know how
a magnet attracts another
and we have made no progress in the last
2 500 years since we invented the
lodestone we discovered the lodestone we
have not explained gravity
magnetism since those days today they
have no answers and you say well it's so
difficult it's impossible i cannot
imagine it's fantastic
we have two
little objects we call them magnets
that's all that's the whole system
and you're saying
we have two objects two rocks
and you're saying you cannot in 2500
years
you have not been able to explain how
this one attracts that one
well there can only be one reason for
that and that's that you cannot see or
touch what's in between them
and if you say there's nothing there
because you cannot see or touch them
then you got the wrong definition and
irrational definition of the word thing
of the word object
if you defined it instead other than c
and touch if you define it as that which
has shape
and that you cannot see or touch this
shape
and then we can make some progress
because now we say there's something
that has shape in there but we can't see
or touch it
and people say well
how do you know there's it's got shape
if you can't see or touch it well the
way we do it in science is you make an
assumption just like you made an
assumption with particles
where did you get the particle
it's an assumption did you see the
particles did you see the particles in
there somewhere between this
is a magnetic field made out of
particles where did you get that idea
and even if you i can see the particles
show me with your particles how you
produce attraction
and that's where you die because you
cannot explain attraction
action at a distance with discrete
particles that's the issue on the other
hand you know i showed you two
mechanisms there uh one for attraction
one for repulsion
for the magnets and it's very simple one
attracts the other when uh threads
you know go in the same direction for
example uh what am i doing here uh
clockwise
i'm going clockwise so they're both
going clockwise right so this one comes
up and this one comes down and they
latch on and pull and if you turn one of
them around now they're going once
counterclockwise the other ones
clockwise they bang and they push each
other away so the mechanism is there you
can't do that with particles how are you
going to explain magnets with particles
do it any way you want you know your
green pixies
do it anyway i'll concede the green
pixies just do it just show me the
mechanism
and of course they'll never figure it
out because you cannot do magnetism with
discrete particles you cannot do gravity
with discrete particles you cannot do
electricity with discrete particles
because what are you going to have a
electron bead flowing from atom to atom
which is the way the mathematicians
simulated today
so where did they get all these
particles
did they see them
or did they make an assumption and say
let us assume right
that there are particles
and then they turn that assumption into
a proof and they just take it for
granted that they're dealing with
particles everywhere
that's what we have today and that's
what we're challenging
okay with that i'll see you on wednesday
and maybe i'll cover space by them
we'll see you then i'll try not to
mislead you this time no i just came up
with that at the last moment i said you
know there's too much material really to
cover today and so i'm gonna have to
skip the space part i'll do that on
wednesday